hello everyone it's Michael BOS from
order flows.com here and this is the
orderflows market analysis for March 14
2017 and today is the first day of the
two-day uh fomc meeting where everyone
and the brother is expecting the FED to
raise rates so you know we sort of and
uh add to that in uh in the east coast
New York there was talk early in the
morning that they could get like uh 20
in of snow um so you know you got a
couple things going on that I think you
know coming into the market coming into
the session uh you know might give it a
a reason to be a slow day and you know
early on it it was a bit slow but then
you know there some interesting things
started to happen and uh you know we'll
we'll jump into it but before we do
first a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures contractor make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results now there's a reason why you
know I have this disclaimer UPF front is
because you know I I don't want people
coming in thinking that you know I have
some Holy Grail I'm trying to sell them
or you know buy my software buy my
course and you'll become a millionaire
next week no you know trading is work
you like any profession you know whether
you're a doctor or a lawyer or an
athlete you know it takes work it takes
effort and you know the reason I put out
these videos is to help you know educate
people on you know on trading um you
know I don't expect people to take my
course and trade 100% like me no I mean
hopefully you could learn something from
you know these videos and take something
of that and add it to your trading now
the tools that I use in this
presentation are the orderflows trader
software which give me the volume
footprint chart the and I got three I
don't know if I'll get around to
discussing all these today but the VTO
flip the U-turn and the transition which
are my own proprietary indicators um you
know I've named them after myself I just
found out over the weekend you know
another company is copying some of my
work and you know they're they're
passing it off as their all new
discovery and orderflow you know which
is a bunch of crap you know I mean it's
funny because you know these are people
that have my software that have known me
for how many years and you know these
are orderflow junk I say orderflow
Junkies you know with people that
understand orderflow and you know are
interested in learning and see what
other people have and and you know
there's several companies that have
coming out over the last uh couple years
have been adapting my ideas I mean you
know am I angry about it n not not
really you know it gives me some
Vindication that you know what I was
doing all these years on my own is is
actually um good and and you know gives
value to the market you know people that
use it but you know at the same time I I
would like to get some credit you know
at least that's why people say oh you're
naming their stuff after you well yeah
there's a reason for it you know I'm the
one that come up with these and I see
people copying my ideas um you know you
want to copy my ideas you know give me
credit for it you know I've worked with
other Traders other software companies
um you know people say hey you know what
I like your idea I like to adapt it to
my to my software you know that's fine
you I I'll work with you on that um you
know because one of the things is you
know since I've developed a lot of these
myself over the years you know based on
my own trading you know the Delta surge
which I give away for free on the
website you know is based on my own
trading and and how I look at Delta on
you know in certain markets that you
know don't put in a lot of volume and
you're looking for signs you know if if
you're looking at a 5-minute chart on a
commodity that's not moving very much
it's hard to make heads or tails when
the market is flatlining you know most
of the day and you know you're looking
for signs in the Delta that's going to
give you a clue so you know buyer beware
buyer beware that's why you know every
video I put out here on the YouTube got
a disclaimer don't come in here thinking
that you know this is going to transform
you into the world's greatest trade
it takes work you know you got to put in
the effort um you know I want to learn
you know I'm not going to just say hey I
want to learn brain surgery and and you
know do a perform a brain surgery in a
month's time from now no it's not you
know there's a lot of work a lot of
Education I have to know so anyway you
know off my soap box and let's take a
look at at the market today um like I
said you know it was kind of interesting
um first thing I want to start in is the
uh five years five years were were very
interesting this morning and
uh let me get it up in
here okay close this
down yeah we were rallying um slowly a
very very very tight Market uh most of
the morning from you know 7 until 9:30
when we started making these new highs
took a while I mean Bonds were making
new highs after nine but you know 5
years moving like a snail finally put in
that new High um you know about 9 about
quarter after 99 um and we just kept
making new highs now this high up here
very very interesting look at this
volume and that's traded here um you
know at the highest 4,000 okay it's not
you know a ratio that I like it's
4.4 you know I'd prefer some sign of
stopping volume up here but you know
even though you don't have it at this
level you know you got unfinished
business people say oh you got
unfinished business Market's going to
come back well it it didn't um today you
know it just sort of sold off the rest
of the day but this look at this these
numbers up here 20,000 12,000 even 10 uh
10,000 here 20 ,000 you know 40,000 here
another 20,000 here 60,000 Lots traded
here now you it's not at the high it's
one tick off the high but the important
thing is you got up here you got a lot
of resistance up here I mean there
people traded a shitload here 87,000
contracts traded normally These Bars you
know it's 10,000 11,00 87,000 so you
found an area where people are happy to
transact okay and what do you take away
from that what the market do after that
after it found this value area where
everyone can trade it sold off right
notice did make a a run back up here
later um you know this is the o2x trade
setup that um I talk
about you know people people that that
know me know about this trade and what
it is you have your high look for a
pullback within two ticks you got your
highs right here at 11622 got up to 21
and A2 it was bid there event so was 21
and 1/2 21 3/4 and then we sold off look
at that boom um but really I mean the
you know besides that o2x setup right
here this is the o2x right here this is
your o That's the high two is right up
in here you within two ticks of that
high and where's your stop your Stop's
just going to be right behind this high
so you're risking four ticks four ticks
right that's what that's one full point
in in the five years five years is worth
like $7 a tick or something 7.81 one
full tick is
$31 you're risking three you know three
ticks four ticks that's it and you know
so you're talking from 11621 what' you
do you went down you know all day long
rest of the day you just went down um
you know 11619 I don't know if you would
have held it all the way there until the
4:00 close but you know this is this is
four ticks here four eight you know 10
ticks there so you can at least you're
risking four ticks three ticks four
ticks and you know you're you're looking
at you know whatever it's just straight
down um you know know you didn't take
any heat on this trade at all but really
the telling point is all this volume up
here yeah it's nice if you get it right
at the high it's one tick off the high
that's good enough for me um you know
people get all caught up with thinking
oh it's got to be right on the high no
it doesn't okay it doesn't have to be
right on the high one tick off the high
is very good level already so you can be
fairly confident that you have the
support that if we come up here what
what do you think it's going to happen
are we going to you know are we just
going to blow through it right you can
see the volume profile a lot of volume
there yeah you have some more volume
down here but you know the important
thing is I mean look at that you came
back up here you hit the resistance
couldn't follow through get passed up
there and you sold off you know that was
um you know one of those take it I say
take it to the bank but you know that
that that was a fairly easy trade to to
take apart and look at now you know the
other thing I want to look at is this uh
three range S&P chart today um I thought
it kind of interesting again we in a
very tight range in the snps
early and you know it was really setting
up to be a a boring day but you know I I
did in the back of my mind think we're
going to get a move because you know we
for the first from 7:00 until about you
know 840 um we were in a very tight
range in the
snps uh just go back
here okay so from
just all right here we are
okay so you know this is 7:00 basically
we're trading between you know
65 you know and 62 you know here it was
this low at 62 is
730 um think we forgot what we had now G
was it we had some number came with GDP
or PP I can't remember off the top of my
head um you know up to 65 a half you got
this area up here it's kind of thin
volume you know just coming back and
forth you know it's 8:00 we're still
trading this was interesting this heavy
volume here I remember you on the volume
profile this area up here very thin
volume I wanted to see us get past it we
couldn't um okay so we we hit there we
sold off you know 832 got this
Divergence again just going sideways
just going sideways at this point I'm
thinking you know there's no sign in the
Delta that hey we could start to move
off this low or anything like that um
you know so something's going to give
hopefully I mean it could just go
sideways all day but you know ever being
The
Optimist I thought we'd get a movement
and and I remember here 843 I thought I
thought maybe this time you know this is
the move I'm waiting for um you know
it's just right below this area with the
thin volume I always like to come back
and blow through that but we got the
Delta we got sorry not the Delta it's
kind a decent Delta 500 but here you got
stacked inbalance and you got a ratio
right after that I remember thinking
maybe this is it maybe this is it and
then what happens you get a bearish
ratio right here
0.04 not the best sign in the world then
here you get a single no print one lot
here again it's right in there you're in
the fourth third bar already from the
Stacked imbalance and it's not going in
the right direction a third bar expect
us to be you know a point or two higher
not back inside of it and going in the
wrong direction Delta is 600 that's not
a good
sign you got this bar here you know it's
lower okay it's the fourth bar still
inside this imbalance again I don't like
being in the fourth bar of an imbal
stacked imbalance and to be on the wrong
side of it you know fourth bar expect us
to be up here so you know that was one
of those things like you know if you're
in it get out get out don't wait don't
sit there hoping that it's going to just
sort of hang around here then pop up I
mean you had your chance it should
happen relatively quick it didn't and
what happens the fifth bar again still
in there you know not even a chance to
scratch it so you know I thought that
was the the first sign of of maybe a
move um but it didn't materialize so
what happens we just but we're still
trading no on the 65 to 62 area you know
we're still in this in this area in here
from 65 1 half to 62 the low is still 62
you see
there okay you start getting some you
know sign you here you got a positive
Delta 1600 price rejector okay you know
but still nothing beyond that you I'd
like to get a ratio if possible or
something else and then this is where
things got interesting started to get
interesting okay what do you got here
this is the Delta surge kicking off
again you can go to the website it's
free download it and you know my - 200
900 1500 so you see Delta picking up
okay maybe we could be making some new
lows here and we do but you know not
like powering through these lows or
anything lower lower couple ticks couple
ticks we hit this area it's 25 okay 25
used to be the ratio that I liked I've
moved it out to about 30 um but I'll
take something if it's 28 okay you know
maybe but again you know it's small
Delta it look a lot nicer if it had
positive Delta and you had a Divergence
but you don't get it um here you have a
Divergence 114 that's this green arrow
there okay then you get another one so
it's 857 you know you get one two this
one you almost but you know not quite um
but anyway you got one two already
forming okay what do you got you know
are why aren you moving away from this
low you're not you're got getting any
powerful Deltas you're not seeing a lot
of buying come in which is concerning me
if we're going to move away from this
low I want to see positive strong
positive Del say you know a th000 or
something instead it's kind of weak it's
486 and then you start coming in 4
negative
1400 what do you get here you got
another Del uh Divergence you're already
looking at three divergences since you
know 5 minutes 857 was your first one
you so you got three okay this one the
Delta it's a bit positive plus 900 on
the back of- 1400 which is quite strong
so taking this one with a bit of grain
of salt so far want to see how it
develops what you you get you get a
bearish ratio positive Delta positive
Delta doe candle small positive
Delta bearish
ratio Delta it's a little bit on it's a
little bit on the strong weak side I
guess you'd call it it's a weak number
but it's fairly it's
decent um then you get some small Deltas
in here 194 173 going back and forth 208
209 so you know these are these are
nothing these are almost I say canceling
each other out but you know you get a
little bit of buying get some selling a
little bit of selling get some buying U
it's just going back and forth you know
it's you know back of my mind I'm just
looking at three failed divergences okay
so you what do I think when I see that
and the other thing you can't see it now
on this but you were forming a new lower
point of control so you had one earlier
a bit higher now you got another one
forming here so what do you got you got
three points of two lower point of
controls uh you know the point of
control had moved down from a higher
level and you got three failed
divergences so you know in the back of
my mind I'm thinking look for a sign
that this Market's going to start to
come off um you know I think it was
fairly lowrisk uh lowrisk trade and
you're just going sideways then look you
get watch this Delta you know small
Deltas in here 9090 198 169 negative
443 boom -300 Delta surge kicks
off okay that's a sign you know you've
already got a couple things that are
giving you a sign that you know Market
could sell off and you get you get the
Delta surge kicking off you know work
can your risk it you know you could risk
it up to the high of that range you know
if if you want it's very Optimist I say
optimistic it's like the worst case
scenario if we got up to 65 and a
quarter of that area you know you
definitely don't want to be short
but there's been no signs that we're
going to get any sort of rally off this
low instead you're getting all negative
signs
so what do you do um you know you can be
getting short somewhere around 59 58 and
a half boom Delta um you know even if
you're getting short in here 59 58 and a
half look at this all this negative
Delta 400 700 2,000 stack selling
imbalance ratio ratio
ratio and you you pushed all the way
down to 56 you know that that's
within you know whatever a
minute okay again still no major sign
that we can start to Rally yet and we're
just looking like we're going sideways
sideways here you get this Divergence
this is
930 got a ratio okay you know that's
positive that's something to go off of
um I always like when you get a
Divergence with a ratio I don't like
that you follow it up with this dogee
bar but you know what can you do um
you're starting to string together some
positive Deltas so okay you maybe we
could start to pull away you know for
but for the most part it just sort of
went sideways made a new low and then
you got three in a row here
again you know this is a setup that I
like but you know take things in context
of the market you got a bearish setup
where do you want to be taking it you
want to be taking it going into a low or
when you get a bear setup take it up
ideally higher you know up near the high
of the day or you know much higher in
the day structure you know I'm always
hesitant taking you know setups going
into to get short going into a low now
that's not to say we can't make new lows
but you know you're going to be fighting
sometimes you know if you're getting
into new lows it could be support coming
into the market that you got to fight
with I'd rather not um you know so we
made these new lows down to 4 and a half
and then we just sort of you know hang
around here you know going into 10 start
to Rally but um you I had to go out
after after 10:00 but um you know that
that was you know that was a decent you
I'll say decent trade opportunity but
you know in the morning at that time you
know this was
uh you had a couple signs at the market
go
lower okay now the next Market I want to
talk about
is uh what was that
soybeans oh you know I'll take a look at
the 10 range e mini chart first real
quick cuz you know it was kind of
interesting um since we were just
talking about e minis but
uh I don't need the profile
though this
morning here again you know you can see
down here this morning basically you're
trading between 62 and
652 from you know from here you know 7
until 9:00 then you come in here you get
this new low you get it stacked
inbalance and again you it's it's it's
interesting you know what happened in
this bar where did you trade back up to
you traded right up to this point of
control you stayed below this stacked
imbalance which again is you know a
bearish sign and where did you trade you
trade it up into this point of control
as resistance as well so you got a
couple resistance levels and the market
respected it um you know if if you
wanted to take a shot on
it you could be getting short here again
still around the 59 level you know in
this bar where around where we opened um
you know I said where was the low four
sorry four and 3/4 so you know not
necessarily a uh full fivepoint move but
you could have got something out of it
you know two three points out of it
which is which is something again you
have that Divergence there um but you
can see how the the selling is weakening
off as you still got positive Delta in
this
bar and positive Delta positive Delta so
the the selling is getting a bit weaker
on your way down so you could possibly
look be looking for a turn in here which
you got right there um then obviously it
went up but you know the other thing I
want to talk about real quick is
soybeans soybeans don't get the as much
respect as they should but it's a great
contract to trade you know one tick is
uh 12 and a half bucks you just like the
e-
minis and it follows order flow you know
Commodities follow orderflow sometimes I
I feel much better than uh Financial
contracts but um yeah I I say that
because I used to be a big uh big-time
commodity Trader um and it's you know
when you're dealing with supply and
demand doesn't get any more uh supply
and demand based than Commodities
so soybeans here we are go back you know
soybeans open
8:30 uh well I mean they're open all
night but you know the technically day
session is 8:30 um this low
here so you got Divergence
75 you see the Delta is kind of
weakening here - 400 -00 positive then
plus 300 you know this is a thing that I
like how you get weakening Delta right
around the either you know on the bar of
the low the bar after or the low of the
bar the low of the day you get the turn
is turning here and you got the Delta
positive strong Delta here with the
ratio and you can see how the market
rallies off this where he's quite strong
again this is a three in a row again you
know what I was saying take things in
context you know you're trading a
bullish sign would you rather take a
three in a row here off the low or would
you rather take it going into the high I
find it's got much better capacity for
upside potential taking a three in a row
taking a buy setup near the low of the
day then taking a buy setup at the High
of the day I mean that's me and my
trading experience you know people will
beg to differ and throw stones at me but
you know what um I've traded all 20
years and I I know what I like to see um
I said you know not everyone's going to
agree with me but if I'm looking for a
place to buy I'd rather do it you know
somewhere on the lower end of the day
than on the higher end and you see you
know $9.95 you even if you know this in
here say you weren't convinced that this
is a low got a three in a row say you're
getting long up here 9.96 you know
what's the trade up to you look at this
trades all the way up in here comes off
a little bit um 10:01 just makes another
run back up here get a little further
high before it starts coming off again
um this is important but uh I'm not
going to talk about
that U what else was there here selling
the balance right on this the low of
this bar that's what this green arrow um
is telling you hey idiot buy it here you
got a ratio as well you got a lot of
things going on in here which is telling
you hey you get a short-term pop here
this is 1016 whates it do again it goes
from uh 10 10:1 10:1 and a half it
shoots up a quick uh you know four 5
cents four or five cents in soybeans is
four or five points in the e- minis you
know this is a $250 move right here you
know that's equivalent from S&P is going
from 2360 to
2365 um you know it's not as glamorous
to trade soy beans as it is say I'm an
e- mini Trader but you know you get some
really nice Moves In in Commodities uh
um this was a nice sell setup in here
for another couple of cents um you know
there were some nice things in soybeans
um you know sort of getting back into
beans it's a bit of a margin hog though
um beans are over 1,000 bucks or you can
trade minis for 500 bucks you know if if
you're trading intraday and and you're
using margin but um but you know it's a
decent contract to trade
intraday so anyway you know I just want
to talk real quick about some of these
indicators this is the
U-turn um
you know going back to the cash you know
8:00 I mean look at this it's picked
picked this low here didn't really hold
um sort of went up came back down then
picks this low um low of the day goes
all the way up here get this again you
can be you fre long off this you you're
probably not going to be getting long up
here again you know would you rather be
long from down here or up here um get a
short here doesn't really work out comes
back against you get another buy here um
you know up to here it doesn't really
work out this sell doesn't really work
out it takes you to the close of the
day um just real quick the mini
transition
uh you basically go back to about a yeah
I'll show you these you know cuz people
oh you know you're not showing the
failed trades 7:16 are you trading snps
at 7: in the morning maybe this one
didn't work out this one failed this one
worked out beautifully um 2360
I mean if you're reading the order flow
you could have saw it anyway or it be
getting short in here at 59 um you know
all the way down to the 56 area it's the
quick three points yeah it would have
been nice if you got this buy down here
but you know what the low wasn't made
yet and it still had a little bit more
capacity to go so yeah if you're getting
long in there you probably would have
been stopped out
unfortunately again something similar
here is a little bit off on the high
yeah it would be nice to get the high up
in here get the sell signal but it came
in there um you get this buy here yeah
it went up went sideways sideways to
higher and that was it so even if you're
buying it in here 59 you up to the 60s
61 62 area to
close uh what else do I
got I don't keep this too long you know
last week was a very hectic week for me
with uh some stuff happening I lost my
power one day and yeah it was just
a bit of a nightmare on some things but
[Music]
um yeah you know that's about I you know
what I'll show you
the my mini da 100 tick
chart it's a nice one usually but today
you know not so nice but still I want to
show you 8:00 you this one didn't really
work out this one did then you got to
sell here which you probably wouldn't
taken this one you probably shouldn't
have taken either
um it's easy for me to say oh yeah you
shouldn't have taken that but you know
what you gotta let the market take you
in the Market's not moving lower it's
not moving
lower um yeah this one yeah it started
to make that move could have got
something here there a nice little bit
of something nothing in here this one
failed that would have stopped you
out this one decent here little bit of a
move no that you wouldn't have gotten in
there this one yeah you know it started
then it came right back up
um it would have been nice to get a sell
signal here this one no it took a little
bit of time to go up but you know if you
took it you would have been stopped out
stopped out on that one but you here you
would have been rewarded on this trade
again rewarded on this trade um then you
went to the
close so anyway um you I don't want to
keep this too long I could go on talking
for hours but I don't want to so thanks
for watching this to learn more about
the trading software used in this
presentation and how you can profit from
waterflow visit my website
www.f flows.com